ja 100 tage krieg in der ukraine 100
tage in dem dieses land versucht sich zu
wehren gegen putins attacke gegen putins
aggression gegen das gesamte volk dass
oka nicht erfolgt und wir wollen uns
heute anders als in den anderen
lagezentrum noch einmal ansehen wie
diese 100 tage das land verändert haben
und zwar eben von ganz oben drauf
geguckt also ganz strategisch drauf
geguckt wir haben dafür eine besondere
karte entworfen in dem man mal sieht die
am 23
februar als sozusagen ja die welt nicht
noch in ordnung war denn wir sehen ja
auch am 23 februar hatten wir hier im
osten des landes bereits die pseudo
volksrepublik die russland einige tage
davor anerkannt hat und gesagt hat als
einziges land der welt das sind jetzt
nationen und die müssen wir irgendwie
befreien und wir hatten natürlich die
besetzte krimi wir gucken uns das ganz
kurz noch mal an wie wie russland ihre
argumentierten die haben ja gesagt wir
haben hier diese volksrepublik no ganz
die volksrepublik donetzk akzeptiert als
staaten anerkannt aber und das ist eben
schon spannend in ihrer gesamten
möchtegern ausdehnung nämlich in dieser
ausdehnung das heißt die gesamte region
lohans von der größte teil zu der zeit
noch unter ukrainischer kontrolle war
und die gesamte region donetsk auch von
der war zu der zeit am 23 februar noch
der größte teil unter ukrainischer
kontrolle da hat man also gesagt als
einer von vielen vorgeschobenen kriegs
gründen diese beiden volksrepublik
akzeptieren wir so wie sie sind und die
werden wir jetzt befreien und zwar in
ihrer gänze was bedeutet nichts anderes
als ein angriff auf die ukraine der ist
dann am 24 passiert und er ist eben
nicht nur im osten passiert das müssen
wir uns noch mal in erinnerung zu rufen
sondern wir haben das noch mal klar zu
machen wir hatten den parallel hier oben
denn angriff auf kiew der direkt
begonnen hatte in der nacht vom 23 24
mit dieser landung in horst rommel die
erinnerung dass dieser kleine ort aber
wir hatten auch überall sonst im land
starke vor drücke einmal in sumy in
cerny lief parallel von der krim hat
mann angegriffen und eben hier im osten
des landes archiv und was wir gesagt
haben du hans und donetsk überall hat
russland das land angegriffen aus allen
richtungen und das muss man sich in
erinnerung rufen wenn putin heute sagt
naja es gibt ja nur um den osten also
wir haben ja bloß diese diese
volksrepublik indem er helfen ein dass
man nicht so putin ziel war eindeutig
von tag eins das gesamte land zu fahren
die hauptstadt einzunehmen die anderen
großen städte einzunehmen und dafür hat
ihm hat ja eben diese ja man muss es so
klar sagen diese blitzkrieg taktik
angewandt also mit schweren panzer
verbänden einfach rein ins land und das
ging bis zum bis bis ende bis ende märz
gegen das halbwegs gut aber die ukraine
haben sich gerade im norden so stark
verteidigt obwohl putin belarus benutzt
hatte um eben hier vorzudringen von
überall und haben die russen aus aus der
region kiew aus der region sharif aus
der region sumi und später auch aus
großen teilen der region aktiv
vertrieben das war der der erfolg
sozusagen den der ukraine nach einem
monat ein bisschen mehr als einem monat
hatten der erfolg russland zwar dass man
hier im süden in der region herrschen in
der region sabrina in der region donetsk
und du hans dass man sich dort immer
mehr verfestigt hat dass man also diese
schnellen panzer vorstöße die am anfang
hatte dass man erst mal rein gefahren
ist und guckt wie weit kommen wir was
einer katastrophe endete weil es ja
keine unterstützung mehr gab für die
russischen panzer dass man das sozusagen
fortgesetzt hat und seitdem das müssen
wir uns in erinnerung rufen seitdem tobt
der krieg erst im osten des landes und
im süden wo eben die besetzten gebiete
mittlerweile kurz vor der aktion stehen
wie es aussieht dort wurde die zeit
geändert das geld geändert neuer
bürgermeister eingesetzt und so weiter
man will also das alles zu einem teil
russlands machen erst seit dieser zeit
also seit dem ersten april haben wir
hier im osten diese an weitere offensive
und die läuft sehr langsam für russland
aber man bringt hier weiter vor immer
kleiner wird das gebiet in lohans und in
donetzk was von den ukrainern gehalten
wird und wie putin das schafft dort
weiter vorzudringen das gucken wir uns
jetzt mit ganz ganz aktuellen videos an
die haben uns gestern erreicht aus der
region luhansk und das sind neue
russische verbände wieder von falschen
truppen ja woher putin die kriegt dass
es nicht ganz klar es gibt weiterhin
keine general mobilisierung in russland
aber es gibt weiterhin
geben die die mobilisierung aller
vorhandenen truppen die irgendwo noch in
russland herum hängen eben in die
ukraine zu kommen wir wissen auch dass
viel geld geboten wird ehemaligen
soldaten oder jungen männern die eben
gesagt wird mensch könnte es ein zwei
monate kämpfen und dafür müsstest du
bloß in die ukraine für viel geld das
passiert weiter wir haben hier weiterhin
einen vorstoss und das ganze sieht hier
das natürlich auch eine russische
propaganda das sieht ja so
professionell aus von wegen haben wir
machen das ja nur als als militärische
vorbereitung mit dem ganzen system aber
wie es wirklich aussieht sehen wir im
dorf schule wo gestern wo eben in der
nähe von oslo bilanz der stadt die noch
von der ukraine gehalten wird wo eben
schwere luftangriffe granatenangriff auf
dieses dorf niederging und das gesamte
dorf in ein flammenmeer verwandelt wurde
so also die realität von putins krieg
auch nach 100 tagen und das ist jetzt
ein kleines dorf wir sehen hier völlige
vernichtung sozusagen dieser dieser
zivilen infrastruktur
und so sieht nicht nur in dörfern aus
sondern auch in großstädten in zivil
roten und es kam uns neue aufnahmen
erreicht wie dort wir können hier
reinhören wie dort der häuserkampf tobt
das also von ukrainern hier gefilmt man
sieht die wohnhäuser die angegriffen
werden die brennen von russischen
einheiten auch dort versucht russland
weiter vorzurücken sie werden es gibt es
nach fünf tagen nach dem russischen
angriff weiterhin straßenkämpfe es gibt
weiterhin ukrainische verteidiger die
versuchen hier etwas dagegen zu tun dass
russland diese großstadt ehemals 100.000
einwohner erobert
das scheint mehr oder weniger gut zu
gelingen die russen haben etwa 70
prozent der stadt besetzt ist das
aktuellste die aktuellste informationen
aber die ukraine versuchen sie
zurückzuschlagen was ich noch ganz
spannend finde ist wenn man sich mal
anguckt wie denn die angeblichen
kriegshelden russlands geehrt werden da
gibt es neue aufnahmen aus lima noch
niemand eine großstadt die fast dem
erdboden gleichgemacht wurde und da
gibt's propaganda aufnahme der
russischen armee und wir schauen uns das
mal an die männer wollen nicht erkannt
werden die helden der russischen armee
wollen nicht erkannt werden für das was
sie gemacht haben das ist relativ neu am
anfang des krieges auch noch nach der
nach der eroberung von mario pohl hat
man gesehen wie dort ja sozusagen jeder
einzelne gefeiert wurde wie die namen
gelesen wurden und so weiter das ist
jetzt nicht mehr der fall die
angeblichen helden die befreier der ost
ukraine wollen auch in russland auch das
russische militär möchte nicht mehr das
sie gesehen werden so ja offenbar angst
hat man so unangenehm ist einem das auch
im land im eigenen land wo er diese
propaganda verteilt wird zu sagen das
sind die männer die hier in der ukraine
tod und zerstörung angerichtet haben
insofern
eine interessante entwicklung dass
russland das ist ja nach außen immer
sagt hier tun dass eben für die ganze
welt sozusagen wir tun dass für die
russen wir tun das für für alle ukraine
dass sie nach innen mittlerweile sich
nicht mehr trauen ihre gesichter zu
zeigen sondern nach 100 tagen krieg
offenbar auch in russland dieser dieser
diese russische aggression zu solchen
folgen führt dass man eben sein eigenes
gesicht als soldat nicht mehr zeigen
will